hello everyone and welcome to another
video this game practically ended not so
long ago but you've been insisting on me
showing it
it's from the World Junior Championship
2018 this is a game from rounds 10 that
just ended and it's a game between every
Iranian Grandmaster Parham Mac Zulu and
Russian International Master Mac Simba
vovan and Parham is some 2650 rated and
Maxim is some 2550 rated so there is
there is a difference in like 100 rating
points which is quite a big deal but
it's a wonderful game I'm sure you all
you all enjoy it as it's a really nice
attacking game and it's really
interesting how the opening goes we have
Knight to f3 in the first move so the
reti opening we have c5 e for v6 d4
we have Knight to f6 Knight c3 captures
captures and a6 so from Knight f3 first
move from ready opening here we are in
the knight of Sicilian and okay we have
a ch3 one of the more popular responses
against the denied of these days e5 and
the knight back to e2 seems like a weird
square for the knight blocking your own
Queen and Bishop but Weiss plan is
Bishop to g5 Queen d3 and castling
queenside so it all makes sense
h5 we have Bishop to g5 Bishop to e6 and
now capturing on f6 Queen captures in
the night the d5 a very nice idea using
this giving of the Bishop giving away of
the bishop repair to get this nice - a
nice d5 square doesn't really make sense
to capture that because after Queen
captures this already comes with an
attack on the b7 pawn and of course you
can block this but the White has a very
nice a centralized Queen on d5 so
instead Queen back to d8 was played and
here we have Queen to d3
Parham prepares the castle we have g6
black prepares to develop the dark
square bishop we have queenside castle
and now comes Bishop to h6 check this is
one of the moves in the game I I don't
really understand
doesn't IIIi can't really find the
reason for this check doesn't really
make sense to give this check because
the white will definitely want at some
points to play King to be one so you
know this is basically giving white a
free move king goes to be won and now
the bishop doesn't seem all that nicely
placed on h6 but okay nice the d7 we
have Queen to a three now attacking the
d6 pawn nice to see five the knight was
going to see five anyway and also now
the d6 pawn is protected Knight to c3
we have castles and now comes h4 you
could push g4 immediately to start
expansion on the King side and you know
start a King side attack but then black
can simply prevent the attack by pushing
h4 okay after castles we have h4 first
now g4 is definitely coming and now B
five before definitely a threat perhaps
not right away but perhaps even this
point can be sacrificed
we have f3 now strengthening the center
and also now preparing g4 and here
another move that doesn't seem to be all
that's necessary rook rook b8 preparing
to push the pawns here seems like the
reasonable way to continue this but
black actually pushes f5 and it seems to
be too much opening of the King but okay
Bishop to e2 and then out comes Bishop
back to g7 here black doesn't use this
opportunity because white could have
captured on f5 and the black doesn't use
this opportunity to close up the game
here now g4 will be met with F captors
and g3 and Poisson and it seems like the
reasonable thing to do but okay Bishop
to e2 and then out comes the Bishop to
g7 so now you can see the bishop returns
to the square where the bishop is
usually posted and I still can't find
the reason why Bishop to h6 check check
was given g4 f5 doesn't really stop
white from playing g4 rather it
encourages white to put g4 we have H
captures on g4 and now F captures on g4
was played h5 seems like a really nice
idea but it's not all that
easy to decide to do this because a
black can push g3 here and after H
garrison G on g6 you can even push f4
and completely closed down at the
position here and now although there are
white is still better here but it's not
easy to you know decide to do this or
not but there is one move that's really
really amazing here and who knows if if
they saw it during the game or or if
this variation was even considered but
it's this Bishop captures on b5 upon
captures and now of course I'm sure you
all can see that Queen captures on a8
Queen captures and the knight to e7
checkmate a very nice sequence but you
know after this f4 it would have been a
very nice resource and of course pretty
much any stronger player would find this
but the parem decided not to go into
this he decided to go F captures on g4
and it's not a forced variation white
the black doesn't have to accept the
bishop of course but the white will be
better then f captain g4 rook H to g1
also an interesting move if I were
playing this position well I don't know
if I just had it over the board like in
a long game perhaps I would also come to
the same conclusion not very likely
although this rock is already on h1 so
my logic would be bring another rook
into the attack but instead he keeps
this rook on the D file and rather plays
rook h 2g one very interesting maneuver
and now comes a rook to b8 King to h7
would have been the best idea here it
seems allowing Bishop captures on g4 and
after Bishop captures rook captures on
g4 now rook to f3 a very nice idea
pinning this knight on c3 as the route
will be x-raying the Queen on a3 but not
an easy series of moves to find so okay
rook to b8 was played we have Bishop
captures on g4 and now Bishop to f7
h5 g captures on h5 and now Bishop to f5
and already we have a very dangerous
position black has to be very careful if
he plays a a weird move or a slow move
then
rook captures and g7 is definitely an
idea
for example if we see Bishop captures
Knight captures let's say Queen to h4 if
black tries to bring some pieces into
the game then you will get rook captures
and g7 King captures rook to g1 check
and after King moves now Queen to e3 you
threaten checkmate on h6 and after this
is prevented for example here you have
to give up some material captures
captures you get rook to g6 and it's
game over Queen has to move and Queen to
h6 will finish the game or you can play
something like Queen to f8 but it
doesn't really matter then Queen to g5
is coming and you can capture here and
again it's game over so a very delicate
position King to h8 displayed black
first on pins and prepares to move the
dark square Bishop Knight to e2 a very
nice idea now the Queen can come into
the game and now rook captures on g7 is
definitely an idea
so here Bishop to h6 not allowing it of
course we have Queen to h3 pressuring
the h5 pawn we have Rock to g8
rook captures Queen captures and now
rook to g1 attacking the Queen we have a
queen to f8 and now what do you play
here well a reasonable idea would be
something like Bishop to g6 but again
it's it's a very hard move to find for
example Bishop captures rook captures
and g6 and now after Knight captures on
e4 you can't really capture here
immediately because if you capture here
immediately we get Queen to f1 check
Knight blocks and Queen to C 1 this will
be checkmate for black but after 94 you
can simply play a 3 or B 3 and then
white is winning Queen will be able to
capture on h5 and all will be well but
ok after Queen to f8 night the g3 was
played no need to risk anything when
White is simply better
rook to b7 and now Knight to f6 and here
seems like black is better off just
giving up there are simply too many
attackers three two knights and the
Queen attacking h5 the bishop is slicing
all the way here the rook is nicely
placed and g1 and black doesn't really
have all that many useful moves here a
queen to g7 would have
allow the white/black to continue the
game for example Knight captures and now
Queen to g5 seems like you're trying to
defend bishop attacks rook rook the rook
attacks bishop and now after Knight to
f6 you captured the night but now comes
in Knight to f5 would a double attack
against the bishop here and after you
give this a nice check here to bring the
rook over into the defense it would
still be you know a much a better
position for white but perhaps black
could hope for something here it's not
all that clear black probably either he
didn't see the real threat or he decided
it was no longer important to try and
save this game he played before and okay
we have Knight captures on h5 and now a
five black continues his attack on the
Queen side as though nothing is
happening on the Kings side nice - h7
with an attack on the Queen Bishop
captures an A - King captures in the
rook captures on h7 Bishop characters on
h7 King captures and now comes Queen to
G for the threat the threats are many
simply checking here and you have to try
something so going to f7 was played this
comes with check King to be won and now
nice the e6 was played there really is
no good move here for black it's all
over but feel free to pause the video
here and try to find a winning sequence
of moves for white so I'll give you a
couple of seconds to decide whether we
want to do it or not some of you said
that I should just pause the video
without saying I'll give you a couple of
seconds well you know this because
you're already a subscriber on this
channel but for know you know new
viewers who visit this channel perhaps
they don't know how it works
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations you are an excellent
checkmater in three and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show if you
found Knight to f6 check you are you
were absolutely correct this was played
in the game and it was in this position
that Russian international master a
maxima Boleyn resigned at the game he
resigned because there's really nothing
to do here if King to h8 then Queen to
g8
Czech Queen captures and rook
the g8 will be checkmate and on the
other hand after Knight to f6 check if
you capture it then Queen to Jake will
be mate in one
ah but on the other hand instead of this
Knight to f6 move if you found Queen to
g8 immediately I think I personally
think this is much cooler as it starts
with a well it's only a temporary Queen
sacrifice but I find it a much cooler I
don't know if you agree so the idea is
the same of course Knight to f6 checking
moves and then rock to g8 will be
checkmate but I'm very interested which
do you prefer do you prefer Knight to f6
check or Queen to g8 immediately so yeah
Knight to f6 was played and a maximum of
one resigned the game
Parham Maxie Lulu max Lulu is the New
World Junior Chess Champion and this is
only round 10 there's still one more
round tomorrow so he became a world
junior champion with one round to spare
and I'm not sure but I've read somewhere
that his rating performance so far as he
is nine and a half out of ten so nine
wins and only one draw his rating
performance is over 2900 average
somewhere it's like 29 30 but also I
read somewhere that it's over 29 60 so
depending on how his the game tomorrow
goes and he's already the world champion
so he he can simply go all out to try to
win the last game and you know grab the
title with in over 300 rating
performance so we'll see tomorrow what
happens I do hope you enjoyed this game
I sure did it was a wonderful reti into
anhidrosis iliyan into a beautiful
attacking game so really I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Santos
Akhilesh for a confucian to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
and I'm back to checking out your
suggestions as like I've mentioned in my
in my Instagram there are you know the
list of suggestions is really really
vast so thank you all and I'll see you
soon